-Here's what people
are talking about.
I saw that today
a White House adviser
compared President Trump
to Houdini...
[ Laughter ]
...because, "If you keep him in
a cage, he's going to get out."
[ Laughter ]
When asked how he knows that,
he said,
"'Cause we put him in a cage,
and -- and he got out."
Yeah, that's right.
He said, "Trump's like Houdini."
If you think about it, Trump
is a pretty good magician,
because in the past year
he sawed his approval rating
in half
and made everyone
who worked for him disappear.
So that's not bad.
I'll give it up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In the meantime, Trump keeps
demanding money
for his border wall,
even though
there are limited funds.
Trump is like that couple
on "House Hunters"
who wants a five-bedroom mansion
on a $70,000 budget.
It's like, "And it has to
have marble countertops.
That is a must.
I won't even look at it."
[ Laughter ]
Still, the White House
is calling the deal
that reopened the government
a win for Republicans
and a loss for
Senator Chuck Schumer.
Well, we actually
got ahold of Schumer,
and here's what he had to say.
First he said...
Then he said...
And then he said...
And finally his necklace said...
[ Laughter ]
It just kept going,
falling as he was --
[ Applause ]
Meanwhile, the White House
announced new restrictions
on washing machines
imported to the U.S.
It's partially
to protect consumers,
mainly 'cause Trump was eating
too many Tide Pods.
And he g--
Don't do that. Don't do that.
I saw that Melania was
supposed to go to Switzerland
with Donald this week,
but is backing out due to
"logistical issues."
It turns out Melania uses
a lot of different excuses
to get out of things
with her husband.
She even has her own excuse
generator to come up with them.
I'll show you how it works.
For example, when Donald asks,
"Do you want to join me
at a campaign fundraiser?"
She says...
"Unfortunately I'm...
actually attending
a fundraiser for...
Oprah."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It works.
-You see how it works?
Next up, when Donald asks,
"Do you want to watch
the Super Bowl with me?"
She says...
"I totally would, but...
there's a government shutdown...
in my mind."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-And finally, when Donald asks,
"Do you want to have dinner
with the British ambassador?"
she says...
"I can't,
I have an appointment to...
take our dog to the vet...
right after I buy us a dog."
Well, that's interesting.
You don't have a dog.
Hey. Oscar nominees were
announced today, you guys.
The nominees...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's exciting.
Nominees for Best Picture
include "Lady Bird," "Get Out,"
and "The Shape of Water."
[ Cheers and applause ]
While the favorite for
Worst Picture is still this.
Ooh, that's unfortunate.
Hey, this is cool.
The History Channel show
"Pawn Stars"
is celebrating
its 500th episode.
To celebrate, the network gave
the producers gold watches,
which they immediately knew
were fake.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, I saw that
a grocery store in Scotland
had to let an employee go
for not being helpful enough
to customers.
But it's kind of an odd story.
Take a look at this video.
-A Pepper robot named Fabio
was recently given
his rolling papers
from a Scottish grocery store
after he failed
at, well, being human.
He allegedly would not
listen to directions
and had often directed people
to the alcohol aisle
when it didn't know how
to answer a customer.
[ Laughter ]
-The good news is, when they
heard he wasn't helping anyone,
he was immediately hired
by Home Depot.
There you go.
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody!